hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well it is si what is
art and institutional analysis Jorge
Dickey will provide a definition of art
that's actually quite complex and rather
ingenious he thinks that it is an
adequate definition of art that
overcomes the problems of earlier
theories of art that that focused on
something that was taken to be an
essential quality of art that turned out
not to be so like the imitative Theory
focusing on imitation the expressive
Theory focus on expression of emotion
and so Dickey is going to propose
instead this this new definition of art
and there's there's really two main
parts to it one of which requires a good
amount of analysis that he provides so
the first part is that the in order to
be a work of art it has to be an
artifact it has to have artifact shoe
ality so and this is if we're talking
about art in a classification snot in a
derivative sense where we you know find
a piece of driftwood and we're like oh
that's art you know but we're we're
actually saying no this this falls
within
the definition of what we're going to
call art what the later on he'll talk
about is the art world the calling art
so artifact shoe ality we're not gonna
worry too much about that instead we're
gonna look at the other part of the
definition he says a work of art in the
class Victoria sense is an artifact and
here we go
a set of the aspects of which has had
conferred upon it the status of
candidate for appreciation by some
person or persons acting on behalf of a
certain social institution that social
institution being what he is here
calling the art world so he says there's
there's four notions involved in this
two of which are very closely connected
so what are these four notions the first
he says is acting on behalf of an
institution in this case the art world
or one of the systems of the art world
could be theater could be painting could
be whatever you like so that's the first
the second conferring of status
conferring the status of being art right
the status in this case leads us to the
third condition being a candidate being
a Canon being potentially something
recognized as that and then finally
appreciation so Dickey thinks that these
four aspects elements whatever we want
to call them features interconnected
notions plus artifact shoe ality give us
a viable definition of the work of art
so he says let's take the first two of
these together because they're so
closely related he says I'm first going
to describe paradigm cases of conferring
status outside the art world then show
how similar actions take place within
the art world and so he brings up you
know a King's conferring of knighthood
of grand juries and ighting somebody
those sorts of things like the ministers
pronouncing a couple man and wife
all of these confer some sort of legal
status upon a person and there can be
other types of status that are being
conferred as well it gives us an example
the conferring of a PhD PhD degree on
someone by university electing someone
as president to a club in this case he
talks about the rotary or declaring an
object as a relic of the church these
are non legal status but these are also
still important status so what are we
talking about when it comes to art he
says well you know the art world itself
is a thing well not really a thing you
more of an atmosphere and network that
confers the status of art upon certain
things there are practices so he says
how his status conferred by this
institution here's what gets really
interesting he says that in a way
analogous to the way in which a person
is certified as qualified for office or
two persons acquire the status of
common-law marriage or a person is
elected president of the rotary or a
person acquires the status of wise man
within a community so an artifact can
acquire the status of candidate for
appreciation within the social system
called the art world and then he says
well how do we know that this has taken
place some obvious means of this would
be you put it on a wall and you might
think of the recent kind of joking thing
where you duct-tape a banana and say oh
there's some art right it's in a gallery
well you know that might confer status
other people might come along and say
sorry that's [ __ ] and I'm not going
to recognize it as art so simply being
in a museum does not yet necessarily
qualify it as
art I mean you might say well you know I
leave a doorknob sitting around because
I'm completing a job fixing the
doorknobs and somebody comes along and
looks at it doesn't see that there's
there's no little tag or anything and
says well that must be a work of art
they're not intended as a work of art
but it could be taken as such so there's
like he says there's no guarantee that
one can always know whether something as
a candidate for appreciation just as one
cannot always tell whether they're given
a person as a knight or married
he says when an object status depends on
non exhibited characteristics a simple
look will not necessarily reveal that
status now it could be indicated by some
sort of as he's calling it badge for
example a wedding ring right in which is
in which case a simple look will reveal
the status and generally in a gallery
how do we know what the works of art is
we look for the title placard maybe with
a little explanation next to it and if
we don't see anything like that we don't
know it's a work of art or not maybe
it's just like a mop that got stood in
the corner and why not sure whether it's
supposed to be a work of art so this
conferring of status and acting on
behalf of an institution closely
connected together those are
sufficiently clear enough there's
there's one other thing that he does say
about status who confers it who actually
speaks for the art world he says only
one person is that is actually required
to act on behalf of the art world and to
confer the status man in fact many works
of art are seen only by one person that
want to create some but they're still
art the status in question may be
acquired by a single person acting on
behalf of the art world and treating an
artifact as a candidate for appreciation
so often he says it's conferred by a
single person the artist him or herself
creating the artifact what about these
other notions being a candidate being a
candidate being something that can
take on the possibility of something
else he says a member of the art world
confers the status so status is one
thing of candidate for appreciation to
other things he says the definition does
not require a work of art actually be
appreciated so this is a matter of you
could say potentiality or possibility if
I create a work of art you know perhaps
a musical composition and then I hide it
away in my desk it is still a candidate
for appreciation even though it will not
come to light until say I die and
somebody pulls it out and they're like
I'm not gonna throw this out let me sit
down on the keyboard and see how this
sounds
likewise other modes of art may
similarly not actually be appreciated
but could potentially be appreciated he
says many works of art in fact go
unappreciated it's important not to
build into the definition of the
classify Kotori sense of work of art
value properties such as actual
appreciation because this would make it
impossible to speak of unappreciated
works of art he also points out that not
every aspect of a work of art is
included in the candidacy for
appreciation uses the example of a
painting now the painting you may
appreciate the painting itself the frame
might also be part of what you're
appreciating go to the you know the
Louvre for example you're not going to
say to the the people there you know I
really would like to see that painting
outside of the frame so I can just get
away from all this ornate you know gilt
edges and stuff like that they'll look
at you like you're nuts
the frame is essentially part of that
the work of art now right but nobody's
gonna pick the painting up and turn it
around and look at the backside and say
oh I love the color on this
canvas this is amazing or look at those
staples how they did that
what craftsmanship that that's I mean
you could do that but nobody does right
and similarly if you're at the symphony
you're out there in the seats listening
to the musicians play you don't actually
like get up on stage and like look down
into the bath soon and say oh it's very
dark in there or anything like that
assuming that they actually let you
let's say you're you know super rich and
you could hire the symphony to do that
you don't wander around checking out oh
look how shiny the the keys are that
saxophone I wonder how old they are let
me smell the tuba and see what the brass
smells like
no no those are not parts of the
candidacy for appreciation for each type
of art there are aspects that we
appreciate in aspects that we're not
particularly concerned with the fourth
thing is appreciation and here Dickey
says I don't want to worry about some
specifically aesthetic appreciation as
if that's somehow something rather
different than other types of
appreciation he says all I mean by it is
something like this in experiencing the
qualities of a thing one finds them
worthy or valuable and this meaning
applies quite generally both inside and
outside the domain of art and he says
some people of you know go on after me
and said this is not sufficiently clear
or aesthetic enough but he says that's
not really a problem so this leaves the
door open to to quite a lot anything
that we find valuable in some respect
means that it's it's potentially
appreciate a bowl which means that this
this definition right of conferring the
status of being a candidate for
appreciation it could be that we're
conferring the status of being a
candidate for moral appreciation or
appreciation in terms of how something
actually
or smells or things like that but in
general it's going to be something that
we would typically think of as aesthetic
he does point out one very interesting
thing he says if something cannot be
appreciated it cannot become art but
that doesn't help us that much because
what can't be appreciated he says some
critics have have said that there are
many things that cannot be appreciated
for example ordinary thumbtacks cheap
white envelopes the plastic forks given
at some drive-in restaurants or
duchamp's ready-mades like fountain and
Dickey says are you sure
why can't you appreciate fountain
couldn't you appreciate the porcelain
and like look at and be well that's very
shiny and I kind of like the whiteness
of that how it reflects things he said
and then he says
similarly thumbtacks envelopes and
plastic forks have qualities that can be
appreciated if one makes the effort to
focus attention on them we might also
think about you know artists such as
bold layer who you know gets gets a lot
of guff in his own time for writing a
poem about essentially a roadkill right
carrion and tries to say that there's
something that we can appreciate in that
most people say Oh a stinky roadkill no
good right but he finds a way to make it
beautiful so really anything could be
made into a candidate for appreciation
if it's situated in the right way in
relation to the art world so this leads
to the final thing he asks well is this
definition that I provided because of
this reference to the art world is it
viciously circular he says that some may
have the uncomfortable feeling that it
is such because if I'd said something
like a work of art as an artifact on
which a status has been conferred by the
art world and then instead of the art
world only that it confers the status of
the candidacy for appreciation that
would be viciously circular why
the circle would be small and
uninformative so the question isn't
whether it's a circular definition Dicky
is perfectly willing to say yeah that's
a circular definition as a matter of
fact anything institutional is probably
going to be a circular definition the
question is is the circle small or large
is the circle uninformative or
informative so he says that I've devoted
considerable space in this chapter to
describing and analyzing the historical
organization on functional intricacies
of the art world so you've received a
considerable amount of information about
the art world which means that I have
given you something that is not small
and not uninformative so it is not a
vicious circle although it is a circular
definition so this provides us with at
least a candidate for a pretty good
definition of artwork in the 20th and
21st century perhaps one that we can
read back all the way through history
and use as an index although now this
means that we need to know something a
bit about the art world in consideration
for any time that we're going back to if
we want to classify things as works of
art
you